Hello Freak bitches.
That's an abused word.
Love.
This is way too many people throwing that word around like a beach ball at a
concert.
It's just too
Butte,
all of that shit.
And then like all of that stuff that people say that when you first see your kid
off,
like they,
they fill your head up on what the fuck you supposed to feel.
I was talking about this on a,
I think on Kimmel,
like I w I saw my kid for the first time.
I was like afraid.
Like I was like,
I didn't have that.
Ooh,
good and start crying.
I was just like,
hey.
And I sorta just put my finger down,
let it,
they like hold.
And when they left me alone with the first time,
like the magnitude of it was,
was,
was definitely huge.
But I didn't feel that whole like,
you know,
the second icon saw my kid.
I knew my life had changed,
but I didn't feel that for like 12 hours.
It wasn't until the next,
but I think here's my head was so filled up on what I was supposed,
I was like having an outer body experience and it wasn't until,
you know,
the next morning and my wife was playing like Stevie wonder,
you know what I mean?
Some chill music and stuff and I was just sitting with their and it just sort
of,
you know,
and you know,
baby baby sneezes or something like that,
you just,
and it just fucking hits you.
Um,
but even then I never had like that blubbering moment.
To me it was kind of scary too and,
and kind of psychedelic because when,
uh,
when my daughter was born,
my eight year old is born.
There was a moment when I was thinking how many babies are being born
simultaneously right now all over the world.
And if you could look at it on a screen,
it would be a swarm of humanity.
Just,
just heads popping out of pussies is
just,
if you could see every baby coming out right now.
And then,
and then I thought at the same time I thought about this baby becoming an old
lady and dying.
And I thought like,
how many old people are dying simultaneous at the same yeah.
Time right now.
Yeah.
See I think it's because everybody,
the hacky thing is you're supposed to say the second I saw my kid,
I bursted out crying and blah,
blah,
blah.
And then so then it becomes like,
if you don't do that,
you're not going to be a good dad.
You don't care.
And all of that type of stuff.
But I,
I just think that that kind of became like that the hackey um,
default thing.
And then I also,
this is all just theories of course,
and I'm not going to research any of this,
but,
um,
I think parents try to outdo each other with their stories about what the fuck
they felt.
And he's just become like,
they're really,
they're really like,
they're not saying people.
Most parents,
and I've learned to kind of already be like,
um,
he'll just sit down next to you like your Forrest Gump and they'll just sit down
and just start talking to you.
So he just said,
you kid,
all right,
well this switch,
you got to watch out for it,
you know,
and I remember my kid and Blah Blah Blah Blah dude.
It's like airplane.
You know what I mean with with a fucking person,
he talks to him and you want to kill yourself.
Just wait until he started going to school and you gotta you got to hang out
with these parents all the time because your kid's become friends with their
kids and then you,
you become friends with these people that you would never be fucking friends
with.
This is what I do is I just look straight ahead and I don't look at him,
I don't respond to what they're saying.
And then they just sort of the top choir and they gradually leave.
You're going to have to go to dinner with them.
Your wives can friends with some lady,
you're going to,
well let's go on a double date.
Okay fine,
you're going to go and this is one guy now he,
he talks and he doesn't look at you.
He tells me these fucking stupid stories about his kid and the basketball team
and he looks at you for a second.
So,
so Adam's in his basketball and he starts looking dumb.
He's like in that did the coach won't put him in the game?
And I'm saying like if he's a good player,
he could play.
How can we not gonna put them in the game and he's fucking bling rambling with
no regard whatsoever for your attention span.
The entertainment value of what he's saying.
He's just the underlying insecurity of not being able to look at you or he's
selling self-involved,
he's self involved and is doing some weird thing with his hands where he's like,
click talking with his hands and I'm going,
Jesus Christ.
It's literally like someone's quitting.
Fantasize about doing to them.
Oh,
I just running,
just running away.
I don't want to hurt them.
The guy's hurt by life.
He's so damaged by live.
I don't want to do anything to them.
I just wanna get the fuck away.
I always picture those people and I have a giant roll of duct tape.
I just put it on the,
it's like a cartoon level speed?
No,
it's cartoon level.
I just put it on their mouth and I go
and the last one it comes up and over their head and then it hangs down.
The whole rest of the tape is hanging down over there awkwardly and I,
and then I just go back to eating or whatever and they just sit there and slowly
have to take it off.
There's some brutal fucking people.
It's,
you know,
there's a bunch of weird people that you,
you get closer to them and closer to them and you find out about their life.
Yeah.
But you know what?
All those people,
I want to do that too.
I'm sure they're talking about me.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
I'm sure they talk about me too.
That's just how it goes.
Seemed like he was in a bad mood all the time.
Yeah.
This is friend of Ron White's,
who's a friend of mine who,
uh,
the first time he met me he's like,
oh,
I don't know.
And Ron's like,
I'm telling you,
he's a good guy.
Like he's a dad too,
and we're all buddies together now,
but he's like,
I don't know.
I just,
I'm guarded.
I've been beaten down by some of these fucking basketball stories.
It's these assholes will tell you and my kitty,
he's a good player.
He's could play or you just want to put them in the game or
just you think of things that you would torture somebody talking about and you
like,
I would never do this to you.
Why are you doing this to me?
You're not even thinking about verbal water
boarding you like in your own little Guantanamo.
That's a great way of describing like,
when is the dessert tray
good.
Say I don't need dessert.
That's part of the problem with hanging around with comedians too was when they
say something like for a good percentage of it,
it's funny.
It doesn't have to be funny all the time,
but a good percentage when you talking to people that aren't funny at all and it
never comes because like surely there's something funny coming eventually.
Nothing,
never,
never something compelling.
Nothing,
not a goddamn thing
and that's when I start thinking like those duct tape fantasies and then I start
making myself laugh and I have to pretend like I'm drinking and then they get
all weirded out because they see something.
Yeah,
look on my face and it just a little thing thing.
Just fucking,
it just goes south.
Yeah,
I'd usually breathe.
I take these breathing exercises.
I do the Wim Hoff method where I took all my breath in and I let like 15 20% now
there's no way you do that across from a person I guess if he's not looking at
you,
he doesn't say it.
Yeah,
I do.
I do like to watch ready.
You'll be making noise,
just got shot and you're waiting for the ambulance.
When you're doing like you just try and
stay,
stay Kanchi but together,
try to stay present.
I try to meditate in the face of overwhelming,
retarded conversation.
Just try to detach myself from whatever they're saying.
Find A,
find a happy place.
Find a peaceful spot.
Yeah.